frohes neues freunde ich hoffe ihr seid
toll einen herzlich willkommen hier auf
jeden fall energiegeladen zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal weiter lieben
freund und zwar spiele mir mal wieder
happy meals das ist bisher nur die level
auswahl allerdings habe ich hier bei den
user stadt mit levels mal wieder laser
luca eingegeben das heißt wir sortieren
das ganze jetzt mal nach dem player und
sehen schon okay hier wurden schon
einige tausende male gespielt
das ist nämlich die levels zitieren für
mich gemacht habt also die lupe und
daher will ich sagen wir spielen jetzt
mal eins von denen laser luca programm
heißt das hier also ich musste irgendwie
nach da vorne rüber hier bin ich jbi
also justin bieber level habe ich schon
geschafft das nächste sandra
[Musik]
ja alles klar
die nächste hürde hier jetzt jule da
komme ich eigentlich auch noch in sieht
darüber glaube ich oh mein gott nicht
direkt ich habe direkt auch max
mitgekriegt jetzt kommt katja krawitz
wie sie es die so hoch ich bin gar nicht
mal so scheiße dem spiel wenn paar
sekunden später mein posting
das soll nicht farbe meine helm ist oder
abgefallen stadt das nochmal das spiel
okay an schwung nehmen und jetzt sagt
über katja drüber oh mein gott okay das
nächste ist baby also die nächste hürde
hier das heißt wir nehmen gerne wieder
ganz viel anschauen und zack haben wir
auch nur noch laser luca das sind
definitiv schwer freunde
jawohl ich glaube man muss wirklich so
davor gehen dass man mit diesen dingen
darauf kommt oder so also ich glaube an
arbeite ich kann man so hoch gar nicht
springen mit dem teilweise spuckt euch
das mal an so hoch komme ich ja gar
nicht an schwung
der ist gut er ist gut jetzt sehr gut
okay dass das haben wir geschafft hier
sind wir sehr schlecht schlecht ganz
okay
ja ich weiß nicht ob es so gedacht war
dass man so dadurch kommt aber ich bin
auch noch gar nicht richtig durchdringen
spät h
okay wir haben es hingekriegt ein
richtiger pro katar steht er jetzt ich
bin ich dachte das level werz vorbei
weil wir zu grün wäre das ist wieso
steht da richtiger proalter ich komm mir
nicht mal durch ich denn bescheuert so
nein ich hasse dieses spiel bevor wir
jetzt gleich das zweite happy meals
level für das heutige video spielen weil
ich euch noch ganz kurz sagen dass sie
eben auch eine neue folge dick und doof
online gegangen ist also eine neue
podcast folge mit sandra und mir wir
reden über das mysterium des schlafs wir
reden über böller verbote wir reden über
ungewollten small talk beim ski sören
link in der infobox und da könnt ihr
euch dann nach diesem video unsere neue
podcast folge an und jetzt geht weiter
halos und andere das ist mein level ich
hab ich eine stunde 15 minuten dran
gesessen also playnow mal schauen was
sie passiert nicht springen
[Musik]
ja ich würde eine eine stunde 50 mal
anders investieren vielleicht kriegt man
mal auf restart level mann soll direkt z
drücken das heißt ich fahr runter und
falle hier weil hier durch
ich halte hier weiter durch werde zur
seite
und fallen
eine stunde 15 ist da reingesteckt sagt
ich klicke nochmal auf restart eindrücke
jetzt ganz schnell auf z genau falle
hier passend runter liege hier drin man
muss ja nichts drücken also wisst ihr
ich drücke jetzt gar nichts
irgendwann verschwindet hat ich werde
darunter gekickt und filigranem ziel
vorbei oder muss ich mich da wo
festhalten ich falle hierunter fallen
hier durch diese komischen teile durch
die jetzt alle aufgewacht werden das
ding geht gleich weg genau jetzt hatte
ich mal ich kann mich da nicht ran
festhalten
ich weiß nicht ob ich zu dummen für ein
level oder ob da irgendein fehler drin
ist aber leider nicht hingekriegt gehen
wir mal wieder hier in ein level von
maxi fisch reihen der letztes mal schon
level gemacht ich weiß nicht ob ich dass
sich jetzt auch schon gespielt habe aber
ich glaube er hat ein neues gemacht also
wie man erstmal über die person darüber
wir sind auf dem fahrrad mit unserem
typen präsentieren
es hat
unsichtbar
[Musik]
gehen wir sind die ganze zeit
unsichtbare sachen und wir werden iran
abgeschossen
was ist
zu brutal das nächste level ist vom
playoff team
halos und andere das ist ein kleiner
roadster im ok also haben gerade schon
level von plate team gespielt aber wir
können uns selbst aussuchen wieder wir
nehmen wären wir nehmen ich würde sagen
ja offen segway ich muss wieder z
drücken und mich jetzt durch festhalten
ok
[Musik]
ich wollte gerade sagen ich habe
verstanden so ich muss zurück um mich
damit leertaste fest aber direkt brech
ich mir einfach meinen arm ab und
harry's daten wir das ganze mal ich
halte mich fest
ich drücke z4 unterdrücke leertaste okay
das sieht gut aus ich bin zur seite
schwinge rüber ich hätte ihnen nicht
richtig
egal wir kriegen das hin so rüber und
jetzt sagt loslassen
ich bin zwar dass die farbe so näher und
grün ist ich drücke zeit meine lieben
freunde ich drück gelehrt hastig hänger
dem ding dann okay das sieht sehr gut
aus die schwinge von links nach rechts
nach links rüber und jetzt wieder nach
rechts und jetzt mal ein bisschen kommt
der kann er da nicht ein bisschen
anspruch nehmen so ok sehr gut und
loslassen
ich hasse dieses spiel also freuen ich
drück ist jetzt wirklich direkt
leertaste und ich hab da hab ich schon
wieder verpackt von daher starte ich das
level direkt wieder neu drückt erhalte
leertaste gedrückt ich hängen ist super
dran
ich denke sogar daran besser kann man
nicht dran etwas muss sich linke rechte
pfeiltaste drücken damit die hin- und
herschwingen aber irgendwie nie passiert
ich nicht so richtig
es war ich schaffe das auch ohne
schwingen so wimmer ich mache einfach
ich lass los und
dieses level von der lieben diana iks
ist das nächste level
ich muss hier das sogar mit smiley drauf
jetzt siehst du aus ist wäre das hier
ist mein eigenes spiel gerade apropos
eigene spielen kumpel du dich entwickeln
seit ein paar monaten mehr oder weniger
schon selbst ein eigenes spiel da
treffen uns jetzt auch am montag wieder
und vielleicht wäre die bald im efd
hauptsache der smiley lebt noch ihr
werdet eventuell bald im app store eine
app kommen
ich sollte da nicht weiter darüber reden
weil jedes mal passiert da irgendwas
schlechtes in dem spiel von daher starte
ich den ganzen rasen jetzt einfach noch
mal von vorne ich hab' ich hab' ich bin
instant am bluten
ich gebe dem ganzen noch im letzten
versuch es geht los sack und die springe
und der erste links okay ich bin gut
gelandet gut gelandet ich bin ich kann
einfach so rüber oder ich kann ich kann
nicht einfach so rüber ich glaube
nächstes level von maxi fisch haben wir
ja jetzt schon level gespielt auch schon
vom playoff team das heißt in dem jetzt
mal das von kaspar xxl hat keinen
kommentar eingeschrieben viel spaß mit
dem augen aids schreibt er ich bin hoch
und hatte da ist schon das ziel das ist
doch nicht das ziel oder aber dass das
ganze level wartet mal ab ließ
raid-level ja kannst du haben wir noch
ein anderes level uns war vom neuling tv
ist laser luca einlauf finde es heraus
okay also ist laser luca ein erlaubt die
antwort ist eine etage weiter unten also
wir müssen da kann ich dann hier wieder
gerade werden es hat jetzt hier in level
ok congo after luca oder sogar richtig
geschrieben die antwort das hängt alles
vom wm hat er einen wert von 18 4 oder
weniger ist ein offizieller laut ok und
hier ist das doch nicht das ziel hat er
was drüber gebaut ob er so weiter geht
sie mit dem laptop zurück langsam
[Musik]
gar nicht mal schlecht allerdings hat
mich das level jetzt gab schon ein
bisschen neugierig gemacht was mein bmi
ist also das ist ja der body mass index
um den kann man hier beispielsweise
ausrechnen also ich gehe jetzt einfach
mal ein ich bin 23 jahre alt ich bin 1
93 euro sondern gewicht in kilogramm ist
85 kilo 2 und normalgewicht ich bin
nicht so ein lauf wie er da steht oder
es gar nicht mehr haltbar glaube ich
hier steht das 19 bis 25 normalgewicht
ist super ihr gewicht ist gesund mit
einer ausgehoben ernährung und
regelmäßige bewegung wird das auch
langfristig zu bleiben ich bin sogar nah
am leichten übergewicht als beim
untergewicht ok kraft das hätte ich
jetzt nicht gedacht allerdings soll das
heutige video nicht vom bmi oder lauch
rechnen gehen oder keine ahnung was
sondern von happy meals levels einem das
letzte mal dass paul hart weil die
oberen sind von maxi fisch und fleisch
immer wieder danke an rpf dem und maxi
fisch dass jeder so viele levels macht
allerdings muss ich ein bisschen fahre
einfach oder wie ich bin einfach ich bin
einfach am fahren mit meinem auto und
ja also wirklich ich finde aber was da
teilweise für levels raus gehandelt
werden von alu crew bereits gerade
gesagt danke an jeden einzelnen der hier
überhaupt die levels macht allerdings
alle sind ein paar wirklich so
ja ja ja das ist ihm selbst ausgedacht
das spiel modus hat er gerade gelesen
hat
super spielmodus die gmbh meine lieben
freunde statt durch das heutige happy
meals dann allerdings auch beenden wenn
ihr euch denke ich möchte bessere level
bauen ich möchte coolere level bauen
oder ich möchte noch beschissener der
level bauen finden liegen luca
dannenberg
[Musik]